I'm starting with my most important
question yeah how do you take your
eggs not raw not raw um I I think I've
got the same egg taste as Barry or
Oliver sunny side up quite well done I
respect that I respect that I'll take
anything but a runny egg seen in the
film didn't make it where he gives him
an egg so Raw it's got the chick in it
with blood and limbs are you joking or
are you being serious it was there at
one point but it hasn't made it I think
it was too dark for any audience but oh
I would expect that from Emerald though
trying to play with something like that
I dig it I love it I love it I know you
can never expect anything from Emerald
can you she's always gon to surprise
never expect she is something else all
right I'm gonna get to your
collaboration with her in a moment but
first I tend to be a little bit of a
backstory nerd when I become obsessed
with film so of course now I need to
know absolutely everything about Duncan
and I'm not not sure how much of this
you really thought through but would oh
my God this is gonna be perfect then
really um Emerald worked with me on it
his backstory we went into enormous
detail actually and then I I lived in
the house in in saltburn when everybody
was in the hotel in the town I stayed
there I begged The Producers let me stay
there so I could feel what it was like
to be in these haunted rooms um you know
in the night on my own and it was a
great experience and did set up I mean I
know to The Outsider it may sound
ridiculous these kind of details but on
some level they communicate I'm sure
they do and as I've got older I I'm more
I don't like the word method but I'm
more into my history of my character
than I than I was years ago I feel like
when you are in a role with less screen
time than others when you don't think
about those details the character
doesn't feel full and whole like a
person that exists withouts outside of
the scen that they're in it's it's funny
because he doesn't speak that much and
it's a very big he's there a lot and
doesn't speak that much and it's a a
friend of mine said that she thinks film
went down when the toris were invented
so maybe a couple of specific backstory
questions did you ever come up with what
he might have dreamed of becoming when
he grew up and then also the details of
how he came to work at salurn well I
think he wanted to be David Bowie as you
know most young boys at that time did um
the details of how he came to saltburn
are interesting first of all I thought
he was the son of the elderly Butler and
just took over that position and had
known it all his life but then we worked
out a scenario where his mother had been
a cleaner there he's from a single
parent and at 14 he went there and
thought I want a bit of this and as soon
as he could at 15 he went to work there
um so that and he is really that house
more than anybody you know um wenar says
to rosand in the in the um Cafe is
Duncan still there of course it's
important that all that is maintain
because he if he's not there it's not
saltman in a in a way it's if anybody's
got ownership of that house it's him
it's very unusual he loves it he genu he
loves them and he loves that house oh my
I have so many followup questions but
you saying he wants a piece of it I feel
like with the hole so well
I know he looked at that house and
thought I want a better of this I get in
and um schemed his
way the head of the whole house head of
the house they're called he'd be
mortified if we called him a butler he's
either Duncan or head of the house I
respect
that given he he's kind of saltburn
himself and I think he knows it better
than anybody else are there any small
details in the production design that
you you picked up on to play this
character that maybe people won't notice
on First Watch but we're important to
you and you think we should keep an eye
on it for the second time around I think
um I don't know about a production
detail exactly in any sort of physical
sense but I think the story of Duncan is
that he's a not a paternal person not a
maternal person doesn't like children
but for some reason and the reason is he
was stuck with these children because
their parents are away all the time he
loved these kids Allison and Jacob he
loved them so the death of um
Jacob um Felix is devastating to him and
I think he feels that probably the most
or lets his feeling out when he's
closing the curtains you know just being
wrecked by the death of this boy that is
such a brilliant scene yeah I know it's
I I didn't know what would come over me
that day I just thought I've got to just
do this and try and feel it and I and
you can hear the gurnie going past with
the body on and it's and also if anybody
knows that Oliver Barry's character is a
bad Soul it's Duncan from the very first
moment he knows I said to Emerald do you
think he knows the detail she said no
because he'd kill him he would kill him
if he knew the details of what he was
doing but I know there's something wrong
with that boy I'll raise the spoiler
warning for this particular question
just in case any of our audience hasn't
seen salurn but given what you just said
I was wondering is Duncan the one that
replaced the glass and if so in the
mirror and if so why not say something
and act in that moment well he would
everything is done seamlessly so there
behind the scenes some you can just
about see it in one of the scenes
actually but there were 30 maids all in
a black dress identical I and 20 footmen
and they all come out into the courtyard
in one scene but the scene where we are
looking for the dead body um uh the body
um uh there were they all came out so
that was this kind of mad mad yes this
enormous staff um would facilitate
anything he wanted go to the mirror in
bathroom number three immediately and it
needs to be replaced and it would be
simply done by two footmen who are
handyman and that's how efficient this
house is that family never have to think
about anything their babies they have
never had to look after themselves from
the moment they were born and um he has
he's from the rough end of life and has
developed um um a liking for the way
they live where does where does Duncan
draw the line what would he have need to
have seen Oliver do to make it so he's
not treating them like babies and
instead stepped in and said there's
something wrong with him and we have to
do something about it he would have
stepped into the family I think Emerald
is right he would have killed him he
would have killed him with his bare and
there is a feeling that he could and
Barry's character sort of knows that on
some level I think he his love and
Devotion to this place is so um intense
he would have taken the law into his own
hands and not have worried the family
you know in in a in a way just um but he
knows immediately there's something
wrong with Barry because he's from that
he's from that world he knows under
privilege he knows what it is to strive
in that case what do you think the next
scene would look like after the end of
the movie because I believe Duncan is
still in
saltburn the ending is yeah he's very
much still there and I think eventually
Duncan would would reveal him eventually
he'd find a way because he know
something is wrong the um the we used to
have a joke um on the set that the the
follow-up film saltburn 2 would be
called Duncan's revenge and it was I
literally have that like written my not
I swear to God this the sequel the
sequel should be like the rise of Duncan
and he's on a mission to take it over
from Oliver it's Duncan's revenge and
you know Duncan probably murders him and
u has retribution and revenge for the
family um that he loved and um yeah no I
absolutely think and also nobody else
speaks except Duncan that's the other
bit of Revenge I would watch this movie
in a heartbeat this is people I
needed so I have to I have to leave you
in a few just to to leave on a positive
note just because I I like I need to
know some source of joy in Duncan's life
what does he do in his downtime how does
he decompress what puts a smile on his
face I think he listens to 80 80s
technopop music in his room full
blast and there's a cat that belongs to
the thing and he looks after that cat
and that's about it the rest in his few
moments of Peace he's listening to craft
work or something quite hard from the
80s from
Germany that's what I think he does in
his little room there's some sort of
like epic sequel poster where you're
sitting like on a throne with the cat
right next to you petting the cat D
saltburn to Duncan's Revenge I can see
it now going like like hell in the
background yeah
exactly well good idea while I sit and
wait for uh that sequel to happen I will
watch this movie over and over and over
I'm Mighty obsessed with it huge
congratulations on saltburn thank you so
much I'm very proud of
it